* Vogelzwitschern *
* Ein Hund bellt,
und ein Hahn kräht. *
Kommt noch jemand mit in den Garten?
Wir köpfen den Rosenkohl,
damit der Rosenkohl grösser wird.
Ich lebe gerne so, weil ich weiss,
woher all das kommt,
was ich zum Leben brauche.
Toni Küchler hatte einst
keine Ahnung vom Gärtnern.
Doch jetzt ist er Selbstversorger
und lebt in einer Kommune
den Traum einer anderen Gesellschaft.
Womit du dich versorgst,
das bestimmt darüber,
ob wir die Chance haben, eine
lebenswerte Zukunft zu gestalten.
Das entscheidet der Alltag.
Und das ist eigentlich der Kern:
dass wir versuchen, so zu leben,
damit wir von dem leben können,
was wir vor der Haustür haben.
Tonis Lebensphilosophie
heisst Permakultur.
Damit hat er
sein persönliches Glück gefunden.
Wie er nun mit dieser Permakultur
einer Randregion
zum Glück verhelfen will,
davon handelt dieser Film.
Balmeggberg im Emmental -
1'000 m ü.M.
Schau ein Marienkäfer!
Bei Rüdu fanden wir
doch einmal so viele.
Oder?
Ronja und Silvan
sind hier oben geboren.
Es ist Ende Sommer.
Der letzte Heuet im Jahr.
Wintervorrat für die Kleintiere,
die Schafe und Kaninchen.
Wenn ich es nicht immer machen muss,
mache ich es schon noch gerne.
Aber wenn ich es immer, immer machen
muss, dann verleidet es mir.
Toni Küchler arbeitet daheim
und 60 % auswärts.
Du kannst ihn auch
in den Hasenstall tun.
Der selbstständige Umweltnatur-
wissenschaftler hat sich für ein
finanziell
eher unrentables Leben entschieden.
Ihm geht es ums grosse Ganze:
die Natur
und eine lebenswerte Zukunft.
Seit er Mitte 20 die Philosophie
der Permakultur entdeckte,
lässt ihn das nicht mehr los.
Eine Art Gegenmodell
zur unbegrenzten Globalisierung.
Was in der Permakultur eben
ein sehr wichtiger Teil ist,
ist wirklich, die Menschen wieder
in die Landwirtschaft zu bringen.
Damit wieder mehr
von Hand gemacht wird.
Dass wieder eine Kultur entsteht
rund um die Landwirtschaft.
Dass Menschen miteinander arbeiten,
Menschen zusammen an einem grossen
Tisch sitzen, sich austauschen,
voneinander lernen,
Beziehungen knüpfen.
Simone, die Frau von Toni,
ist vor 13 Jahren mitgezogen.
Eine Städterin vom Zürichberg,
die mit Landwirtschaft
so gar nichts am Hut hatte.
Es gib sehr, sehr viel zum Lernen
und auch zum Staunen.
Wie seid ihr hierhergekommen?
- Frisch verliebt.
Ja, wir stiessen zufällig
auf dieses Haus.
Das fanden Freunde von uns.
Das war im "Tages-Anzeiger"
in Zürich ausgeschrieben.
Es war ein Ferienhaus,
das einer Familie gehörte.
Wir waren eine Gruppe von Leuten,
die Lust hatten, so etwas zu machen.
Als wir starteten, fanden wir,
dass wir nicht aussteigen,
sondern ins Leben einsteigen wollen.
Und wir wollten das
nicht allein machen.
Die Idee der Permakultur entstand
in den 70er_Jahren in Australien.
Ihr Gründervater ist Bill Mollison.
Heute ist es eine weltweite,
stetig wachsende Bewegung -
Menschen auf der Suche nach einem
ganzheitlich-nachhaltigen Lebensstil.
Moderne Technologie inklusive.
So, who is interested in coming?
So, he wants to come
with the whole band?
Will you organize ... äh ...
Anhänger?
Trailer.
Der Balmeggberg ist eine Art
Lehrstätte für Permakultur.
Ich begegne hier Männern und Frauen
von überall her.
Für Kost und Logis
wollen sie anpacken,
während Wochen oder gar
Monaten, wie diese beiden Dänen.
Das ist meine erste Erfahrung
mit biologischer Landwirtschaft
und Gartenbau.
Als ich hierherkam
wusste ich, da muss ich bleiben.
Marco Büttner gehört
wie Simone und Toni zu denjenigen,
die das ganze Jahr
auf dem Balmeggberg leben.
Auch er verdient sein Geld
im Wesentlichen auswärts.
Durchfall hat er auch nicht. Es ist
also nichts Lebensbedrohliches.
Für alles und jeden
scheint man hier Zeit zu haben.
Schnelllebig komme ich mir dabei vor.
Das ist ein physisches Leben.
Man ist sehr nah an der unmittelba-
ren Arbeit mit den Lebensgrundlagen.
Wir versuchen, möglichst viel eigene
Nahrungsmittel zu produzieren,
möglichst viel von unserer Energie,
die wir zum Leben brauchen,
herzustellen
und sehr nahe an den Urkreisläufen
des Lebens zu sein.
Das fühlt sich für mich
sehr stimmig und richtig an.
Man folgt hier oben keinem Guru, will
nicht Aussteiger sein und trotzdem:
Danke fürs Kochen, Sophia.
Eine Botschaft haben sie sehr wohl
die Balmeggbergler.
Für all das, was auf der Welt pas-
siert, bei dem man das Gefühl hat,
es kommt nicht gut, ist das eine
Antwort, dass man sagt:
Hier arbeiten wir im Kleinen aktiv
daran, Konflikte zu verhindern.
Konkret würde das dann
beim Speiseplan heissen:
Eigenes oder lokales Essen
kommt auf den Tisch.
So ganz konsequent sei man aber
längst nicht immer, sagt mir Toni.
Ist es ideologisch?
Nein, gar nicht.
Ich versuche einfach, da möglichst
in meinem eigenen kleinen Rahmen
die Entscheidungen
so gut wie möglich zu treffen.
Ich glaube, man kann sagen, das ist
nicht ideologisch.
Unten im Tal in Trubschachen
hat Toni Küchler sein Planungsbüro.
Wenn meine Kinder
in der Schule erklären müssen,
was ihr Vater arbeitet, ist das
für sie eine Herausforderung.
Es ist für mich schwierig,
ihnen das zu erklären.
Bei seiner Arbeit bewege er sich
auf dünnem Eis, meint Toni.
Was am Ende des Tages
bei seinen Projekten rauskomme,
sei oft ungewiss.
Sicherheiten im herkömmlichen Sinn
scheint es in seinem Leben
nicht zu geben.
Ständige Veränderung und
Anpassung als Lebensprinzip.
Getreu dem permakulturellen Motto,
die Welt vor der Haustür
zu verändern,
ist sein Wirkungsfeld
in erster Linie die Region:
er hat Alternativstrom
aus der Gegend initiiert,
und sein neustes Projekt
soll das Dorf beleben.
Besichtigung vor Ort
mit Interessierten
und dem Gemeindepräsidenten.
Ich freue mich über die Einladung.
Hier stehen wir
auf der Baulandparzelle.
Geplant sind zwei Mehrfamilienhäuser
mit je fünf Wohnungen.
Also eigentlich bis zum Weg?
- Ja.
Dann haben wir hier ein Hofstett.
Ein Teil davon
würde auch dazugehören.
Dahinter steht ein Bauernhaus,
das wir auch übernehmen möchten.
Noch weiter hinten
hat es ein Stück ebenes Land.
Das könnte man brauchen,
um Gemüse anzubauen,
z.B. für die Selbstversorgung.
Ich kann mir vorstellen,
dass gewisse Leute lieber ruhige
Einfamilienhausbewohner hätten.
Sie haben Angst vor Neuem,
das man nicht kennt.
Trubschachen ist nicht
einfach per se ein schönes Dorf.
Es hat eine sehr laute Strasse,
es ist eigentlich ein Strassendorf.
Es ist nicht einfach,
Leute hierher zu bringen.
Mit diesem Projekt
ist das nun eine Möglichkeit.
Die Verbindung zwischen
Landwirtschaft und Wohnen
kann man in der Stadt
nicht machen,
oder es ist sehr viel schwieriger.
Davon träumen sehr viele Leute.
Wie viele Randregionen
kämpft auch Trubschachen
seit Jahren gegen die Abwanderung.
Trotz stattlicher Anzahl Arbeits-
plätze in Industrie und Gewerbe
steht viel Wohnraum leer.
Wir merken einfach auch, es sind
manchmal gerade die Zugezogenen,
die für unsere Region kämpfen.
Das ist bei Toni der Fall.
Wir haben einen Arzt
in der Nachbargemeinde,
der für den Spitalerhalt kämpft.
Am Schluss sind es die Zugezogenen,
die sich
für unser oberes Emmental einsetzen.
Das ist eine gute Erfahrung.
Dass er immer sagt, Sie seien nicht
so anders. Sehen Sie das auch so?
Das sehe ich schon nicht ganz so.
Sie sind schon anders und eigen.
Wie sie sich anziehen. Gut,
bei dir geht es jetzt im Moment.
Nein, aber ...
Seine Frau Simone unterrichtet hier.
Sie sieht schon anders aus
als eine traditionelle Lehrerin.
Sie hat mehr ... Gut ich habe jetzt
auch etwas aus Wolle an.
Aber rein optisch ist es schon
eine andere Lebensart.
Sollte dann dereinst
diese Permakultur-Genossen-
schaftssiedlung gebaut werden,
dann natürlich mit Holz
aus der Region.
Toni hat da schon vorgespurt.
Grundsätzlich möchten wir
zwei Mehrfamilienhäuser machen.
Den Platz kennst du ja.
- Ja.
Toni arbeitet
mit einer Zimmerei zusammen,
die auf eine Bauweise
umgestellt hat,
die mehr aus dem Holz
der Gegend macht.
Wir haben sehr, sehr viel Wald.
Der grösste Teil
geht unverarbeitet aus dem Tal.
Damit ist
die ganze Wertschöpfung fort.
Nun behalten wir
einen Teil hier im Tal.
Das Holz verlässt das Tal erst,
wenn das Haus fertig ist.
Also wir behalten die ganze
Wertschöpfung hier hinten.
Massivholz, mehrfach geschichtet,
ohne Leim und Metall verdübelt
wird zu Fertigwänden verarbeitet.
So kommt mehr
als nur bestes Holz zum Zug.
Die mittleren Lagen,
die grosse Menge,
das ist die schlechtere Qualität
aus unserem Wald, aus unserem Holz.
Das ist die grosse Menge, die wir
brauchen und die hier anfällt.
Für diese Produktion
brauchte es neue Maschinen,
eine Riesensache sei
das gewesen, sagt der Zimmermann.
Toni hatte bei der Neuorientierung
der Firma seine Finger mit im Spiel.
Wenn man so eine Anlage
anschaffen will, braucht es Geld.
D.h., mit der Bank zusammenarbeiten,
Businessplan, Geldbeschaffung, usw.
Bei all dem
hat er uns sehr geholfen.
Wenn er von Permakultur spricht,
was ist das für Sie?
Bringt das einfach nicht.
Das finde ich eben
gerade das Schöne:
dass es Leute gibt,
die überhaupt nicht damit arbeiten,
die das nicht als Begriff brauchen,
und doch sieht man, es gibt es.
Ich selber lebe nicht so.
Ich habe ... Wie soll ich sagen ...
... ökologisch nicht
die Disziplin wie Toni.
Das heisst?
Bei mir steht das Wirtschaftliche
mehr im Vordergrund,
damit wir hier die Wertschöpfung
behalten können,
damit wir den Landwirten
das Holz abkaufen können
und damit sie
mehr verdienen als im freien Handel.
Wirtschaftlich muss es auch
bei den Balmeggberglern sein.
Ich staune aber,
mit wie wenig das geht:
60'000 Fr. Einkommen braucht die
Familie von Simone und Toni pro Jahr.
Bis wo muss ich es nicht halbieren?
Bis da.
Bis da muss ich es nicht halbieren.
Hier wird Beinwellsalbe
für den Verkauf gemacht.
Das spült etwas
Geld in die Gemeinschaftskasse.
Wir sind wahrscheinlich schon
ein bisschen ein spezieller Haufen.
Ich finde es überhaupt
nicht speziell.
Ausser, wenn Freunde fragen:
"Wie macht ihr es,
wenn ihr das und das nicht habt?"
Was z.B.?
Ein paar fragen mich z.B.: "Wie
macht ihr es ohne Geschirrspüler?"
Wie macht ihr es?
- Von Hand.
Viele Hände für viel Arbeit -
Grundbedürfnisse
werden quasi kostenlos gedeckt.
Bist du gern in der Küche, Silvan?
- Ja.
Warum?
- Hm, das ist eigentlich ...
Ich bin auch gerne draussen,
aber Gartenarbeit, jäten,
ist nicht so mein Ding.
Lieber kochen?
- Ja, lieber kochen.
Zahlreiche Wechsel
hat diese Kommune schon erlebt
und sich immer wieder
neu zusammengewürfelt.
Nicht nur schmerzfrei.
Ich stelle es
mir durchaus schwierig vor,
seinen Platz hier
immer wieder zu finden.
Was uns als Paar betrifft,
sind wir nicht jeden Tag
für uns alleine,
sondern wir sind immer auch noch
in einem grösseren Gefüge.
Und können uns in einem
grösseren Gefüge austauschen.
Wir hängen auch nicht so
bedingungslos vom anderen ab.
Also, wenn der eine nicht zuhören
mag, dann kann man auch
zu jemand anderem in der WG gehen,
und sich dort austauschen.
Man muss dann schon wieder
miteinander reden können,
aber man hängt
nicht so stark voneinander ab.
Ob das für alle immer so einfach ist
mit der Austauschbarkeit
in der Gemeinschaft?
Es ist Tag der offenen Tür
auf dem Balmeggberg.
Danke fürs Interesse. Wenn euch
etwas auffällt, dann sagt es uns.
Dann können wir
auch noch etwas lernen.
Aus der ganzen Schweiz
sind sie ins Emmental gepilgert.
Warum sind Sie heute gekommen?
Ich wurde von Françoise eingeladen.
Sie hat mir erklärt,
was sie hier machen.
Ich wollte das anschauen,
wegen der Permakultur,
und dann ging ich natürlich googlen.
Das Prinzip ist:
Wir pflegen den Boden,
nicht in erster Linie die Pflanze.
Wir versuchen durchs Kompostieren
so viel Boden aufzubauen,
dass sich die Pflanze mit dem
bedienen kann, was sie braucht.
So wird der Aufwand, die einzelne
Pflanze zu pflegen, auch kleiner.
Alles ohne künstlichen Dünger
und ohne Chemie.
Ich finde es spannend:
Auf so kleinem Raum,
haben sie trotzdem so viel Ertrag.
Und dann wird alles
in der Gemeinschaft verarbeitet.
Ich bin auf dem Land aufgewachsen,
und da war das gang und gäbe:
die Hühner, die Hasen.
Man wusste noch nichts
von Dünger oder so.
Es hat etwas von früher.
Und doch geht die Permakultur weiter.
Mit den Mitteln der Zeit. Anleitungen
oder Gütesiegel gibt es keine.
Von der Natur lernen, sich einordnen
ins System. Immer nach dem Grundsatz:
Trage Sorge zur Erde und den Menschen
und teile fair.
Also, es war nicht immer richtig.
Zu einem solchen Leben gehört auch,
wie bei jedem anderen Leben auch,
dass man manchmal zweifelt
oder verzweifelt.
Was ist denn der Zweifel?
Man zweifelt,
ob man es durchziehen kann,
sei es vom Finanziellen oder
von der körperlichen Arbeit her.
Sie sind nicht so aufgewachsen. Wenn
Ihre Eltern das sehen, was sagen sie?
Schnitt!
* Toni lacht. *
Nein, ich kann es schon erzählen.
Wir sind beide in einem ganz
anderen Umfeld aufgewachsen:
Einfamilienhaus, Kleinfamilie.
Und ...
Ich verstehe auch,
dass sie es nicht ganz verstehen.
Das ist auch recht so.
Und trotzdem profitieren Sie
von diesem Hintergrund.
Auf jeden Fall. Wir konnten z.B.
dieses Haus mit 27 Jahren kaufen.
Das war natürlich mit der
Unterstützung der Eltern möglich.
Und dann auch mit der Bildung
und mit all dem, was wir mitnehmen.
Beim Projekt der Wohnsiedlung
in Trubschachen
hat sich mittlerweile einiges getan.
Herzlich willkommen zur Gründungs-
versammlung dieser Genossenschaft.
Viel Interesse für ein Projekt,
bei dem manches noch unklar ist.
Die Finanzierung steht zwar,
aber ob es
zum Verkauf des Grundstückes kommt,
ist zu diesem Zeitpunkt noch offen.
Trotzdem
wird an diesem Abend entschieden,
wie das eben aus der
Taufe gehobene Kind heissen sollen.
Also, dann hätte
die Genossenschaft Sonnhas,
was sie für Trubschachen
auch sein will ...
Ich glaube,
das ist ein Applaus wert.
Mich interessiert
der gesellschaftliche Wandel.
In der Natur arbeiten,
die Verbindung.
Was macht Sinn für mich?
Was macht Sinn für die Umgebung?
Wir müssen nicht versuchen,
Steuerzahler anzulocken
mit wunderbaren Häusern
für ältere Ehepaare mit grossen
Löhnen und dicken Vermögen.
Wir wollen ein lebendiges Dorf sein.
Ich bin gekommen, weil meine Frau
das Projekt sehr gut findet.
Ich habe mich am Rockzipfel meiner
Frau gehalten und jetzt bin ich da.
Ich finde Trubschachen ein Loch.
Wer sagt, ich soll dorthin gehen?
Wenn meine Frau geht,
gibt das eine schwierige Situation.
Und was meint Toni, der Realist?
Vielleicht komme bei solch einem
Riesenprojekt alles ganz anders.
Werfen wir nachher
noch ein paar Schneebälle?
Die meisten Praktikanten sind weg.
Thomas, der Däne, ist noch da.
* Die Kinder
sprechen durcheinander und lachen. *
Die Gemeinschaft auf dem Balmeggberg
plant das nächste Jahr.
Sechs Monate im Voraus
ist jeweils klar,
ob grundlegende
Veränderungen anstehen.
Und wenn auch -
alles scheint im Fluss.
Im besten permakulturellen Sinn
ein selbstfunktionierendes System.
Wenn Sie über die Jahre zurück-
schauen, können Sie ein Fazit ziehen?
Wir sind immer noch da.
Heisst das, dass Sie das
nicht gedacht hätten?
Ich bin eher positiv überrascht,
dass es uns immer noch gibt
und es uns gut geht.
Und leben Sie mit 70
noch in einer Kommune
oder vielleicht
alleine in einer Wohnung?
Oder sogar jeder für sich?
Also mit 70 hoffentlich
schon wieder. - Was denn?
Wieder in einer Kommune.
Vielleicht zwischendurch einmal
ein wenig alleine.
Aber dann mit 70 ...
Mit eigenem Bad.
Und dann noch mit Toni oder nicht?
Das kann ich mir schon vorstellen.
- Wir werden sehen.